So in addition to Chris Wallace and Neil Cavuto,
we've seen Fox News host Eric Shawn sort of
start to play the role of a so-called truth
teller on Fox News.
And I always have to issue caveats by truthteller
on Fox News.
I merely mean he acknowledges that Donald
Trump lost the election, that it's a very
low standard.
And Chris Wallace and Neil Cavuto have been
willing to say that.
Eric Shawn also is willing to say Joe Biden
won.
And on Fox News, this is sort of a controversial
truth to be told when half the network still
refuses to say it.
And in a little bit, we're going to talk about
how Fox News has radicalized its viewers to
the point that they are now too radical for
Fox.
But part of what's going on is that some people
are trying to acknowledge basic truths on
Fox and they're getting crushed.
And anchor Shep Smith was one of those people
on Fox, but he left now on CNBC.
And maybe Eric Shawn is the guy taking Szeps
place to some degree.
Check this out, Eric.
Shawn, Fact checking some of Donald Trump's
obvious lies that Trump told on the same network
just hours earlier in his interview with Maria
Bartiromo, the complete brownnosing Trump
sycophant.
We played clips from the Maria Bartiromo Interview
earlier.
Here is Eric Shawn starting to pick it apart.
This election was a total fraud and it continues
to be as they hide the problem we have, we
go to judges and people don't want to get
involved.
That is, of course, President Trump claiming
massive voter fraud this morning.
His words, they stuffed at the ballot box.
It was a, quote, fake election.
All this despite the fact that his campaign
has failed to prove any of this in court.
In fact, government, election officials, experts
and others, many of them Republican, including
Trump, appointed officials, say that the president's
claims are false and absurd, unsubstantiated.
He does, though, promise to reveal the alleged
fraud in court, including a slew of affidavits
from people who say they did witness election
wrongdoing.
But legal experts note affidavits are not
necessarily fact.
I like this because in just 30 seconds, he
puts the entire case up front to the Fox News
audience.
He's making claims for which there is no evidence.
Affidavits aren't necessarily fact.
And we really have to keep talking about that.
Sworn affidavits are a form of evidence that
is sometimes admissible and sometimes not.
And it is up to a judge and jury to determine
whether it is credible when a when an eyewitness
testifies in person in a trial because they
testified, that doesn't mean you necessarily
believe everything they say.
You may find their testimony credible or not
or not credible, or you might find it accurate,
but irrelevant to the crux of what is being
discussed, much the same way these sworn affidavits,
people could be lying or not.
People could be telling the truth as they
remember it and be wrong, or they may be telling
the truth and be right.
And those truths might not really mean anything
about whether Joe Biden actually won some
of these states and affidavits are just like
anything else in terms of evidence.
Then, Eric, Shawn hilariously wants to talk
about these supposedly massive dumps that
Donald Trump mentioned.
Take a look.
Let's break down to some of some of what the
president claim this morning.
He says there were massive dumps of illegal
votes and in Biden's favor, specifically pointing
out Detroit.
Here's the president.
You just take a look at just about every state
that we're talking about, every swing state
that we're talking about, and they did these
massive dumps of votes and all of a sudden
I went from winning by a lot to losing by
a little.
Well, officials say these are not illegal
dumps.
That's just the counting of the many mail
in ballots that are entered into the computer
system.
Are these illegal votes?
Is that a proof of massive voter fraud?
Well, there's no evidence to substantiate
that.
And when you talk to Republicans in these
states or on the election board, very few
of them are saying that at all.
The problem here is that I don't know if the
average Fox News viewer understands the meaning
of this language, because when the Axios reporter
says there's no evidence to substantiate that,
what it means is it's a claim without evidence
whatsoever.
There's an invisible purple elephant right
here next to me.
You just can't see them because they're invisible.
Well, there's no evidence to substantiate
that.
What that means is it's a claim I've made
and there is no reason whatsoever to believe
it.
That's what it means.
I don't know that that really works for the
Fox News audience.
Rand Paul actually is one of the people who
jumped on this massive dump story.
He tweeted, quote, Interesting Trump margin
of defeat in four states occurred in four
data dumps between 134 and six.
Thirty one a.m. statistical anomaly, anomaly,
fraud.
Look at the evidence and decide for yourself.
So what Rand Paul means is during a five hour
period on election night, votes were being
counted.
He's acting like the 36 second passed five
forty one a.m. mark.
All the votes came in, flipping eight states
from Trump to Biden.
So now it was election night.
Many states aren't even allowed to count mail
in ballots until polls close, thanks mostly
to Republicans.
And so overnight, during a five hour period,
votes came in from various states and results
were updated to reflect that they're making
a controversy where none exists.
Let's look at a little more of Eric Seans
kind of pulling apart of Trump's lies.
Yeah, they picked up seats in the House.
The president says thousands of dead people
voted.
Here's that.
There are a lot of dead people that so-called
voted in this election.
But dead people were in some cases, in many,
many cases, thousands of cases voted.
Officials point out that does happen sometimes
either clerical errors or maybe a husband
or wife votes in the name of someone who is
deceased.
That's a felony.
Was that enough to change this election?
Statistically likely not.
When you just look at the number of deaths
that have been out there that you know and
you transpose that onto the universe of ballots.
So another talking point debunked dead people
voting and then finally hear Eric Shawn pointing
out what this is really all about.
Finally, HODs, it seems that we have a president
who he can't wrap his brain or mind around
the fact he can't process the fact that someone
who he thinks is so inferior to have won the
election, maybe or maybe he's just establishing
a predicate for running in 2024.
So, you know, I you know, I don't know what
the president's overall long term strategic
plan is here.
If there is a plan or even if it's strategic.
But we know, at least rhetorically, he's not
accepting it and he's clearly laying the predicate
for a run in 2024.
As Eric Shawn points out, Trump cannot wrap
his mind around the idea that he lost to someone
that he considered was very much inferior
to him.
So two things here.
First of all, the takeaways, the only take
away you need factually about the allegations
is there's no evidence for the things that
Trump claims in public in the court filings,
the things Trump claims they don't put in
the court filings because the lawyers know
they're not true.
In terms of Fox News, what's going on here
is that they have radicalized their audience
to be too radical, even for Fox News.
And that's what I want to talk about next.